[Music]
your blades are sharpen with
Precision flashing your favorite point
of view point of
view I know you're waiting in the
distance just like you always do just
like you always do already pulling me in
already under my skin and I know exactly
how this ends I let you cut me open just
to watch me bed gave up who I am for who
you wanted me to be don't know why am
hoping for what I won't
receive falling for the promise of The
Emptiness machine The Emptiness machine
[Music]
going around like a
revolver it's been decided how we
lose cuz there's a fire under the
altar I keep on lying too I keep on
lying too already pulling me in already
under my skin and I know exactly how
this ends I let you cut me open just to
watch me play G up who I amever you want
in me to be don't know why I'm open what
I won't say falling for the promise of
The Emptiness machine
I only wanted to be part of
something I only wanted to be part of
part of I only wanted to be part of
something I only you wanted to
be let your cop me open just to watch me
play gave up who I am for who you wanted
me to be don't know why I'm open so
I am falling for the promise of
The Emptiness ma shame the empty for I
want to
be Happ
I The Emptiness
[Music]
Mach hey friends I hope you enjoyed that
flow it has been a long long time since
I have done one of these videos to a
rock song but hey Lincoln Park is back
in the top 40 so it seemed like an
excellent opportunity to let my rock
freak flag fly say that 10 times fast um
real quickly if you want to grab a set
of those orb poy Pros you can do so and
get them for 10% off when you use the
promo code Drex factor with a zero
instead of an O at checkout over at
ultra.com once again that is Drex factor
with a zero instead of an o thank you so
much to ultra poy for sponsoring this
video and giving me an excuse to go out
and flow uh also thanks our o to the
Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys pyer light toys and Ultra poy for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all these amazing companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links down in the description of
this video and big thanks to the non-
business friend of the channel That is
Becca beckon thank you so very much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission and finally uh this video and
all the videos on this channel would not
be possible without my amazing
supporters on patreon in particular I'd
love to give a shout out to my flow
patrons who are listed on screen right
now thank you you all rock and if you
out there watching like the videos that
I produce and you'd like to see more of
them easiest way to do that is to head
on over to my patreon at patreon.com
drexfactor poo and sign up to support
them in the future you can also get
access to some awesome rewards but the
best part is you'll be helping me out in
my mission to bring po spinning and flow
Arts to the whole wide world so go check
that out please and thank you and if you
would like to check out more flow
sessions like the one that you just
watched I will go ahead and include a
link to a playlist of those videos down
in the description as well as up here on
screen if you are watching on YouTube
please take care yourselves get out and
flow today and I'll see you with a new
video real soon peace out oh and if you
live in the United States go out and
vote next
week peace